auch aus im netz mittlerweile wird
aufgerufen zu demonstrieren und es wird
auch zu warnung aus aufgerufen wir
schalten zu meinem kollegen peter wilke
er beobachtet die demonstranten dieses
camp der querdenker schon in den letzten
tagen peter wie wann denn die reaktionen
im camp von der initiative querdenken
auf diese gerichtliche entscheidung in
der ersten instanz der moritz bei dem
camp waren wir gerade also so gesagt bei
dem was von dem camp noch übrig
geblieben ist denn das kennt musste
heute gegen 13 uhr geräumt werden denn
das wurde auch verboten und dieses
verbot für zeltlager wurde nicht
aufgehoben das camp ist jetzt also nicht
mehr dort präsent wurde aufgehoben
stattdessen übernachten die leute da
jetzt in kempen in camping bussen mit
denen sie nach berlin angereist sind
haben wir waren gerade da haben mit den
menschen über dieses diese entscheidung
gesprochen da war natürlich die der
jubel groß also die die initiative
querdenken die demonstranten die fühlen
sich jetzt auch so ein bisschen als
sieger gegenüber der versammlungsbehörde
und man hat aber auch gesagt ja das war
uns natürlich schon klar dass das
entschieden wird
und wie reagieren denn die protestler
die demonstranten jetzt auf die
nachricht dass zum einen die polizei
jetzt angekündigt hat in die nächste
instanz zu gehen oberverwaltungsgericht
wird angerufen bis 18 uhr 30 sollen die
entsprechenden unterlagen dort eingehen
möchte man denn auf die behörden zu
gehen findet denn da so was wie ein
dialog statt zwischen beiden seiten
wie also zwischen den behörden und der
initiative scheint ihr einen dialog
statt gefunden zu haben wie das
verwaltungsgericht heute mittag in ihrem
statement sagten wurde ja ein hygiene
konzept vorgelegt und da wurde ja
darüber gesprochen wieder morgen die
regeln eingehalten werden sollen also da
durchaus einen dialog stattgefunden ob
jetzt da zwischen polizei und diese
meldung mit der polizei dass dieser
einspruch einigen ist ja ganz frisch da
kann man jetzt noch nichts konkret
darüber sagen da muss man abwarten wie
der jetzt die entscheidung fällt auf den
einspruch der polizei aber ich glaube da
führt kein besonderer größe besonders
großer dialog statt
jetzt gab es ja diverse weitere demo
anmeldungen es wird jetzt von einer
teilnehmerzahl um die 30.000 gesprochen
hat der veranstalter diese initiative
das alles noch im griff das ist ja eine
sehr dynamische situation
die polizei hat heute mittag in ihrer
pressekonferenz mitgeteilt dass diese
ganzen kleinen demonstrationen dass man
meistens zur demonstration mit 12
personen müssen zwei personen mindestens
sein damit sie als versammlung durchgeht
dass das offensichtlich ersatz
kundgebungen waren nach als das verbot
noch galt das waren über 5100
versammlungen angemeldet worden und laut
veranstalter querdenken waren die auch
so dazu da um so alt die versammlungs
würde zu fluten und so ein bisschen zu
erreichen dass nicht pauschal alle
abgesagt werden sondern das hat
irgendeine zugelassen ist das ist
natürlich jetzt nicht mehr relevant so
lange das verbot aufgehoben ist und die
demonstranten ganz normal morgen zu
ihrer einen großen kundgebungen gehen
können wir sehen im hintergrund sehen
wir diesen aufmarsch der auch hier an
dem brandenburger tor ist da haben wir
gerade mit der polizei darüber
gesprochen noch ist nicht klar ob diese
versammlung überhaupt angemeldet ist es
sollte sich darum zwei versammlungen
halten wie zusammengeschoben wohnen und
eine von der bewegt sich jetzt hier
wieder weg die polizei klärt eben ob die
jetzt vielleicht aufgelöst werden muss
aber es ist klar zu erkennen geben bei
dieser demonstration hier die auch zu
querdenken zu den kronen gegnern hört
dass da ganz offensichtlich der abstand
nicht eingehalten wird
aber eingehalten werden soll laut diesem
beginne konzept bitte lasst uns noch
kurz über die auflagen sprechen die
jetzt vom gericht in erster instanz
verhängt worden sind
dabei geht es um abstand der bühne der
videoleinwände aber es wird nicht über
die maske gesprochen die steht ja nun
mal morgen im mittelpunkt dieser
demonstration es wurde nicht darauf
hingewiesen dass masken zu tragen sind
fühlen sich davon die menschen vor ort
bestätigt jetzt morgen keine maske zu
tragen
natürlich fühlen sie sich bestätigt
wobei auch irgendwie davon auszugehen
ist dass morgen sowieso keine maske
getragen worden wäre das war mir schon
am ersten august gesehen dass da keiner
eine maske trägt und das haben uns die
demonstranten auch gesagt dass da nicht
die besondere absicht bestand masken zu
tragen aber natürlich fühlen sie sich
jetzt als sieger bestätigt dass diese
maske ja gar nichts bringen würde und
auch hier unter freien himmel nicht
nötig ist zu den abständen zwischen den
videoleinwänden müssen ja morgen 300
meter abstand sein
dazu sollen die ordner das
verwaltungsgericht sprach heute von 900
ordnern die dass die die organisatoren
bereitstellen achten dass die abstände
eingehalten werden da muss man jetzt
wieder abwarten ob das natürlich dabei
auch die abstände eingehalten werden
wir können im hintergrund sehen heute
funktioniert das noch nicht anfang
august hat das auch nicht so gut
funktioniert und wir haben dann auch mit
einer demonstrantin gesprochen von
querdenken dies aus der schweiz gekommen
und als ich sie gefragt habe ob sie denn
morgen die abstände einhalten möchte
meinte sie nein ich brauche keine
abstände halten einhalten ich möchte nur
alle umarmen ich möchte alle lieben sie
wollte dann auf mich umarmen aber das
habe ich dankend verneint